when searching mythology for rare and
unique supernatural creatures they can
be found across all regions and today
we'll be taking a look at some Eastern
Asian mythology with the Chia Lin or the
ki-rin as its referred to in Japan the
jaelyn is composed of several different
animals
much like the chimera of greek mythology
and it appears in chinese japanese and
korean mythology it is often depicted as
having the body of a horse or a deer but
its body is covered in fish scales and
sometimes engulfed in fire not too
dissimilar to that of the Chinese dragon
other time it's depictions have slowly
changed with some having a singular horn
leading to the Chilam being compared to
the unicorn and sometimes even being
referred to as the Chinese unicorn the
chileans origins are rooted in Chinese
mythology but it does appear in other
regions of Asia going by the name of the
kid in in Japan and they give in in
Korea sightings of the children were
often few and far as they were widely
regarded as one of the rarest and most
powerful creatures they would only
appear during the reign of a good and
just ruler or before the death and birth
of a sage the Chilam was a regal and
revered creature that was only seen in
the wild during times of peace and
harmony many believed that its presence
would signal the start of a golden age
the creature is normally shown as calm
and benevolent refusing to harm other
creatures and even walking on small
clouds as to not damage a blade of grass
the Chilam would never do harm to any
soul that he considers to be good and
pure but when threatened the chilling
can incinerate anything with breath of
holy fire the Chilam for the most part
keeps supernatural powers hidden until
it feels the need to defend itself or
other people from the actions of
evildoers the purity of the chilean has
led to the animal being seen as a symbol
of justice and wisdom with many
considering them to be omens of good
fortune
because of the Chileans association of
greatness it was quite common for
Chinese emperors to desire the
appearance of one as this would help
legitimize their reign and enhance their
reputation amongst their people there is
a tale of a Ming Emperor in the 15th
century who returned to China off their
voyage from East Africa with his fleet
with him he bought a pair of giraffes
these giraffes were acquired from
merchants when his fleet landed in
modern-day Somalia the Emperor claimed
that these animals are magical and he
used them as a way to legitimize his
greatness this led to many of the
Chinese people associated in comparing
the giraffe and the cheer Lin this could
also be seen in other cultures as the
Japanese word for giraffe is very
similar to that of Kidd in the Chilean
is a truly fascinating creature
not only because its appearance is
unique in majestic but because it shows
us that looks can be deceiving it may
appear as a fierce and dangerous
creature that you would never wish to
come across but that is the exact
opposite of what the Chilean truly is I
hope you guys enjoyed today's video if
you did then let me know what you guys
thought in the comments below but as
always I've been your host mythology in
fiction explained